all right
[Music]
um let me just start talking on this and
I'll get you to where I would like to
work tonight okay um first I don't think
that anyone learns an art and then you
study some art I think that's a
very academic point of view and when I
say academic I mean it's not truthful
it's not it's not accurate it's it's
made it's a point of view made for the
production of a discourse
and then that discourse goes on to serve
something so for example the idea as as
modern iido today iida today they want
to know what ensei studied uh and then
they're picturing that you know he
combined this and that and he came up
with that this or that and this is
this is just not how a human
being Works um we are much more organic
we're not at all like computers like
that where I take this information I
take that information and I I come up
with this kind of Harmony of the two or
some equal measure of the two that's not
what we
do the ego tripartite mind goes around
and it structures
everything it it it takes
Parts it recognizes them as Parts but in
its recognition of Parts it takes other
aspects and makes holes okay
and those parts and those holes come to
uh construct our identity and so as you
study
something and you study multiple things
and you have multiple experiences there
are this radical process of parts and
holes being made that come to make up
you and when you get to the holes that
are
you there there's no distinguishable
Parts in
them so if someone says to me today are
you doing
Kempo I I say yes they say are you doing
iido I say yes somebody asked recently
when are you going to do uh do you still
do Keno it's like yes yes my iido is
keno and then someone said well oh could
you make some videos on Keno dude that's
all I've been
making okay uh because it's just
me it's just
me everything that I do gets filtered
through the me through the ego
tripartite mind everything gets filtered
through
there what I do is me it's my
art what my mind calls it calls it Kempo
calls it AO but I know that's all
delusion so I don't care what you call
it
this all gets compounded by the fact
that I know the ego tripartite mind is
not the whole of me there is another
aspect of me that transcends that mind
and therefore there is another aspect of
me that transcends both Kempo and iido
both the division both the communion
that so it doesn't matter at
all what you call
it it is both me and not
me I'm both being described correctly
but also
incorrectly so taking that and coming a
little bit more down to earth I would
like to use a dichotomy that Mr Parker
used so I trained with Mr Parker he had
a huge influence on how I think about
a martial art
fighting which is the the Kinesiology of
human be human violence this is
all Mr Parker or Mr pick it's not Chiba
Sensei it's not
ensei so this is why my
iido not only looks different it does
not only function different but even at
basic Elemental levels why is your your
foot like that why is your knee like
that why is that angle there and thereby
why do you use that timing not this
timing and thereby why are you in that m
not this m all that is from these two
men not not the iido lineage that that
is why my iido does not look like other
people's iido they don't have that
lineage the
Kempo practitioners that have that
lineage they're not doing iido Kon
but if they did it would look the same
if they trained at my level it would
look the
same so a dichotomy that Mr Parker gave
us as a tool is the difference between
science and
style Mr Parker wanted our movement to
be scientifically
valid by which I would tell you he meant
kinesiological sound
and he knew from his study of martial
arts that often times people in the
martial arts are not kinesiologic
sound but they have the impression or
the delusion my word that they
are because they look like this teacher
or that teacher or they look like this
poem says to look or this Maxim says to
look and he would call that
not soundness but
style and I would put before you that
iido is driven not by
kinesiological sound movement but mostly
by style movement stylistic
movement uh Christopher Hines pointed
this out when he he said that there's a
there's a an aesthetic that drives iido
today and he's 100% right there's more
people people interested in that in the
adoption of the look of what has become
iido then they are in kinesiologic sound
movement movement that is
biomechanically
capable of gaining advantage in human
behuman violence they're they they they
have made the mistake the one that
Parker pointed out that
style because it looks like like this
teacher or looks like this Maxim or
whatever is biomechanically sound is
kinesiological sound is martially sound
it's not
true what you see today with bracing
angles and this erect posture then this
lifted chin this exposed
throat those pelvic tilts that put all
this pressure into the lower back all
those Samurai poses do you see
we know is from Western influence
they're all military Dr they're all
artificial
postur that are not this is the best way
of movement they just have come to be
known as this is the best way to move
but they're not they're just
style and I would say that even in a
marshal lineage like Chiba Sensei you
still had style you have you have major
style not kinesiological soundness okay
and this has a lot to do
with what is my foot angle and where is
what is my weight
distribution and as I said as we go into
soncho 3 or even any of the
soncho why I do that move like this and
not that move like that
okay um and I'll give you a a quick
example of how I changed Sono one part
one and how I saw people
struggling falsely
unnecessarily because they would not
free themselves from style and just move
into kinesiological soundness okay and
so because I have my form is different
not not just in its execution but even
in in its architecture from just one
generation above chibba sensei's form so
I'll show that now okay Sano one one uh
it begins with a ski so he
skis good okay and we change this SC
there you go all right that's where he
is and that's his mind and in the form
as it was originally shown and is still
done this way by a lot of people uh you
would do your normal K that gu which is
a three-step process so I would take my
left foot and I would take my right foot
get the angle and then finish with that
ten Con on the
angle it would looks something like
this and it all looks
fine I so people do it over and over and
over okay
but if we look at
it and he has the right M which is there
he has full penetration of my torso okay
and then I take that step off the line
going forward or at least to the
90 and then I now take the other foot
and I'm moving the
K and now i t
con and now somehow I end up over here
okay so this is clearly not the right
mind and people start doing some weird
things to make that work or look to work
when it didn't work one of the most
common things is that you don't actually
ski with the right
penetration he was never going to hit me
anyways and now I could do that and you
can see I'm getting a little in the area
okay or I combine this under penetration
where he would never hit me
with a step that goes out this way you
see and exposing all of this area and
being very twisted if I didn't expose
it and then I come out and now I got in
the right area
okay but this makes no sense he goes
again to give my flank to him that's not
in a weapon fighting system now I would
never do that and you could go to your
to your Firearms he goes and I wouldn't
go like that this is a very difficult
shot to make no one would ever do
that I would keep my gun point it at him
pointed at him
okay even if I had to do that weird
twist there all right so eventually in
the K Class People realize this is all
kind of weird especially when cha and
they started having us uh do a double
ski a double ski attack boom and okay
that reveals something that I knew from
the sidelines as I was being told to do
this weird
step that I had three steps to his one
step and that never works in weapons
fighting so again he goes one step and I
was going to go one two three and that
just never works in weapons fighting and
the double ski reveals it he goes one
and you're going to get hit every
time so what people did eventually in
San Diego was and like it's so weird
that you can't do it
okay is they did a little baby
step this
thing oh good here one
two one
two it makes for all this tension in the
body and it seemed like well I know I
got to have my right foot forward and my
right hand
forward and that that's what they were
doing
but I'm not sure it helps the double
ski and that's why we went okay the four
wants my right foot forward my right
hand forward and that's why we
went with the sheto
tank and when you add his true
penetration
then the technique Works see
there whereas the other little baby
steps it works a little better but not
really I'm all jammed up and I'm open to
the Double C Okay C it's right
here is also why in our
form I don't block I don't block I don't
have to block because I'm not clearing
the
line inside the weapon Arc this is the
weapon Arc I'm not ever clearing the
line inside the weapon
Arc do it
again or inside the radius I'm inside
the radius so I need some deflection so
he doesn't follow
me even on the other another
one if he does true
penetration on inside the radius I need
something keeping it to the left as I
move to the
right on the ushido
Tenon true penetration I've got inside
the radius so I don't have to block
which is why when we go embryonic I'll
touch and hit
but when we go for real I'm hitting him
as he's hitting me okay and it's just a
defensive path of action it's not an
angle of deflection okay and now it
makes more sense you did one step I did
one step I hit you as you hit me that's
Marshall okay me doing three steps you
doing one step you not throwing anything
and waiting for me to finish those two
steps that's not Marshall that's sty
okay so we're going to look
at the
particulars from or the particulars of
the footwork and the hip angle and all
this kind of stuff to get rid of what I
to me always looks weird when IO people
are standing in what is clearly
stylistic removing the weapon
stylistically instead of
kinesiological sound ways okay
okay so um stand in the beginning okay
cool stay there all
right so Sean's been with me for a while
but he has lots of ferite iido in him
and this is
similar in that you don't have your dck
you're not standing like this right so
he he's not standing like this okay but
is still different enough
okay um Taylor what do you what can you
describe as
different um the back heel isn't up on
the rear on the rear foot okay so the
weight is uh kind of like
um it's not a very doesn't look like a
very athletic or
mobile stance from that point and so
often times when we begin the form like
Sono 3 because nothing has been
committed yet you want to be as neutral
as possible and so you want to adop what
Bruce Lee called The phasic Stance and
which we use in Kempo for those times
okay and that made you not overcommitted
to the rear heel okay so even in in in
modern Kendo you'll see they'll be with
that rear heel up okay and so what
Taylor's talking about is often times
when there is there no commitment yet
because I don't know where I'm going to
move I don't want a base I don't want a
grounded foot okay and so my rear heel
is is more up if it's
not it's not being
weighted which it will be if it's
bracing okay and so
sometimes I'll have the heel down as in
this
case but not here because then it's
going to be bracing yours is back more
so if you
look and you pick this arm up you have
this line This diagonal line and I would
like to see it straight on the midfoot
so you would have to bring this foot
in okay and that's going to make your
Han
me she's zti
turned okay so here is she's enti right
underneath my hips that's where my feet
go and when I go to ha me is I'll turn
to the
90 okay so I square one
foot to my angle of attack or defense
and the other foot will go to the 45 and
my feet are still underneath my hips
okay so let's let's re angle that leg
where you had it a little more very cool
okay got it and now to show you how
we're off leave your leave the balls of
your feet where they
are and turn them Square to the
45 yeah there you go and you can see
that you're wider these feet are not
underneath your hips okay so put them
underneath your hips and this is your
shenai and this is also where
your bones and all your matter are
stacking and can be stacked over the
midfoot see when you open your
feet then they're falling inside that
that weight is falling inside you see
that and you have to use
flexion to not have your knees go in and
stuff you have to hold them out do you
get it so instead you want to be able to
stack your bones so that means feet are
under your hips okay and so from She's
that is shenai and now from shenai you
straighten the foot to the angle the
opponent's at and you bring that other
foot into a
45 and that is on me okay and what
you'll notice that something else that
happened is now you'll have an angle to
you you're still trying to force it
don't force it be comfortable
so you want that 45 on the chest okay go
back where your foot was you see and
then do what you wanted to do and now
you're square and there's this is
actually not Han me because Han me means
half body you see and you're as wide a
Target as you can be and you're trying
to hide behind this little sword but you
got a lot of you showing you see that
all right so let's bring the foot the
feet where we want and then make sure
we're angled behind the sword there you
go okay and this is now on me now if you
want and you take that heel off because
you're grounding on the midfoot of the
back foot and you're more athletic like
this could go wherever and you can move
you see wherever you need to as fast as
you can do do you get it okay so I'm I'm
just going to chop this thing at you got
it you better not let it hit you you
better get the off that line there you
go back in
it you don't have to dock just move out
so
okay and now start deepening Your Feet
Again Square your body up and you'll
feel how much slower this is
go back to narrow
base feet underneath you weighted you
ready be light be light be light ready
to move there you go that's it there you
go
okay let's do the other
one I know you don't do
it
okay and the same thing oh and you can
see is you're not you're
dead Okay especially if we
get like we preached for Samurai I got
all this tension here
right can you do it for
me tense up there you go stand up
straight good look how samurai he
looks you see and
can move see and you wouldn't ever stand
that way if there was a big knife fight
you would not go
stability you're like no no no no no no
no mo mobility Mobility now
okay um let me have you both play with
that okay you can penetrate as much as
you
want good
okay wait if that's the goofy one let's
do it right so get on the tight rope
turn your feet out get that tension in
your body
good and so you guys see
like especially if if we're not going to
start attacking like you know like for
iido people but we're we're over here
right and I'm trying to do get a beat on
up up and I'm I'm going to go for the
tackle and stuff right so he gets in
that goofy tip Rob
stance and he holding his tension right
I'm
dead
right doesn't work it's not it's not
martially sound it's not kinesiological
sound it's just
stylistically reproductive
that's all it is okay all
right a very common
one use for the Maia touch just whatever
there you cool okay a very common
one is that I
drop I move this over here and I drop on
the side of my weapon I don't know where
you need to be to see that
I drop my weight is over my
feet
okay
boom and the obviously there's some
weight connection okay such that he
grabs I can put my weight in my hand you
see and drop my weight and there's some
weight
connection but when I put this
underneath to do the same thing is
there's more
weight plus whatever internal aspects I
get do you see
so very common
thing is you'll see the Deep stance
again okay and now as you're as you're
doing this you've made things worse
because weights out here weights out
here weights here where my butt is
whereas if my feet were closer the
weight's more here there's weight on my
feet weight on my feet weight on my butt
line and I'm closer to the Joe I'm now
spreading it out see and the Joe will
get
lighter boom gets lighter you see you
actually pick me back up okay so you see
a lot of people do this and there's no
real power in the weapon
okay so I have to stack my
bones and I'm going to
use H me again which is just Sheen time
okay so I'm going to drop
weight and once the weight can't drop
anymore over the midfoot line I bring it
over the Joe it weights on the Joe okay
so if you come over here get off on the
side I go
here Joe's out there or my weight's here
and you lift the Joe you'll feel
that there's no weight really on
it but if I were go ahead and grab it if
I'm pushing my weight over it you're
going to feel my weight as you try to
lift up now I add my weight
dropping and you can see there's way
more weight on that thing so ground I'm
doing the same move and there's a lot of
weight on the
weapon so a lot of people
think this is Marsh sound but it's not
this is
style Marley sound is
here okay here's where I want to be a
lot of people
think that you're pinned you're not
pinned you're not Pinn because you
really
haven't compromised your knee bend your
knee Bend doesn't go any further than
normal so as I doing the move you can
move you can move just as quickly okay
so we'll have you do that so you can see
just get into those different
positions good you're on the side so
they usually drop their butt lower they
think that's it and then you can see so
the resistance to the lift is how much
downward Force you would have in this
Oshi okay so we'll do that one more time
okay lower your butt like you got really
you went really low okay there's no
weight on it okay and that just gets
exponentially
worse at the distal end there's just no
weight on it you
see and now we'll have you go into find
chenai first cuz you're going to stack
the bones then find Han me you turn the
foot toward the angle there you go okay
and you
drop and what you're doing here is like
you're doing
your back squat feel that line that's
your posture the downward line there
which is the downward line of the Joe
okay actually turn there okay and then
it'll be impossible for me to lift that
thing up on you okay got it and again
you could see oh yeah that's way heavier
than the other one
okay make sense yes all right have you
guys play with that so here's here's
this is very common too that a lot of
people can't lower the butt without
pointing their toes out this is going to
heal weight you so this is going to move
the your your your body mass line of
gravity further away from the Joe okay
so he's got his toes pointed away from
each other this is going to heal weight
him and you can lift and see how light
this is and you'll feel your weight go
right away to your heels do you see okay
and now the common one like you get
really low do you see it it'll just make
it worse CU there's more weight further
away from the Joe as you lower the butt
it's actually lighter okay all right now
I'm we'll try the right one so find she
zenai then turn your foot towards the
line of attack cuz we are fighting
someone yeah you got to turn a little
more it should be there you go okay and
then you have that back squat line over
your Joe line okay all right and you'll
see you brought your weight closer to it
okay there you go okay good and that's
all downward Force onto the onto the
tuba and into their Center okay all
right um let us go to the book
in and we'll try the technique with
the uh sugii forward to make sure you're
not pinning yourself okay because you in
particular sometimes you don't bend your
knees you just lean over the Joe line
and that that will pin your feet you do
bend your
knees and then I want to fast stashi you
don't have to ski but I want you down
and in okay let's go let's Marshall up a
little bit
like
good get your weight on
there good come down the subba
no your foot went
off you're going to go
down then in there you
go one
more and in there you go you see his
foot's not pinned okay and once you have
internal skills you can bounce the
weight that's going down you can Bounce
It Off to move the front foot forward
okay which is what I do to you guys all
the time so that's why it's so fast okay
okay now last let's have you have the
joke just
a okay and you you did you did uh juki
so that last one yes there you go okay
and we're looking at this this stance
here okay got it okay so let me check it
out all
right so if you pay
attention you have an angle
on this ankle do you see that okay yeah
you're yeah that would be an
exaggeration of the of the angle okay I
want to pay attention to that
okay and then this looks good okay and
what I'm noting here is you see how this
hip is more
forward than that back hip which it
should be and for this back hip for this
hip to come forward for this quad to
close this knee should be in alignment
with
it meaning let me push it that's that's
incorrect and as you go here incorrect
sneeze out of alignment I know that you
feel that you don't have a base at that
angle you see which a lot of people will
do a Toshi and they have to step off the
line This Way CH says they would have to
do that all the time and it's
because the
hip knee foot alignment is not there and
you start to now have horizontal forces
cutting across your stance okay where
you're not strong because you have kind
of adopted a tight loope stance you see
because I'm now penetrating I gave a
purpose to my stance and I'm going to
take advantage of my biomechanics for
that singular purpose in this case ad me
okay but within your Emi you're adapting
for the fact that your stance is narrow
and the way you do that is this qua
closes a little allowing the knee to
come and that requires the foot to be
slightly turned in there's the there's
no way around it so if you for example
turn your foot out
try right do you see let's even do
straight and you'll feel tension here
here do you see there's now tension
across the inner knee and as a result
you've had to unturn the hip and not
close the quaw and now there's no quaw
power into the ski you see that and
you're still injuring your knee if you
turn your foot out it's all this is now
Amplified even worse okay and strangely
you this line gets worse you see and
this that other line gets worse too okay
and it's strange because a lot of people
think that this is actually helping you
stay on that line but it's not because
you're generating this Force line right
and then the other one I'm not going to
say it's the the exact opposite is this
is the force line to the front do you
see that makes me want to fall that way
Who and the other one is more through
here it cuts through this line here and
it's going this way okay so why is that
important that second line it cuts
through here which is why when when I do
that you feel that okay all right why is
that important because when you do the
ski you see that that's what gets hit
okay and that's where now you're there's
no Mass penetrating the target it
bounces off in uh in that remainder of
inertia right uh Newton's uh law of of
opposite and equal and it now your
stance absorbs it going this way okay
all right so let's go back to the other
correct hip knee foot making that foot
slightly turned in okay and uh let's pay
attention to this angle here remember I
said you're too far forward on this
angle okay and let me show you when you
you start to apply
pressure and I want you to keep the
posture got it so I'm going to apply
pressure you're going to keep the
posture keep it hard use all your
muscles to keep it and you tell me where
you start to feel the pressure keep it
hard come on come on almost in my uh
rear the thisin okay but I I I'm moving
you I don't want to move you use your
muscle use your muscle use your muscle
where do you feel it in the back yes you
see in the lower back okay which is very
very vulnerable okay so just your just
your lower
back is actually holding what we think
the leg is holding you see a lot of
people think oh this is very strong
because you have the leg it's only as
strong as your ability to keep your back
into that angle and that the back's not
very strong okay all right so here's
what we're going to do
instead is bring this foot in this back
foot so it's not straight right but more
drop I have more weight onto the front
leg but there's an actual knee bend on
that face there and I will bring it out
as you did a little more you see I'm off
that tie Thro because my power is going
to come from the qua it's not going to
come from a bracing angle and my back
trying to hold the utility of the
bracing angle okay okay so I'm a little
wider what I mean by that is in your
first stance you're on this line on this
one I'm not do you see I'm I'm over more
okay got it and now don't use the Jo
yet think
of this
angle being more vertical H can you get
it as opposed to more angled angled
you're going to put it on the arch you
see and that's why a lot of chi Sensei
people that thing comes up all the time
all right you're going to be trying to
keep your anle your ankle angle as close
to 90 you can't but you that's what
you're thinking all right okay stay
there give me your hand and now you're
bracing on the back foot and your torso
can now relax you see I'm going to start
pushing harder
and you'll never feel it in your body do
you see okay get the Joe out don't get
overzealous and go back to that other
one keep your back neutral right ground
the back
foot and you can see how much more
relaxed right you
see okay and so uh totally different and
really difference is one I'm going to
put this Joe through your chest or
you're going freaking back there or two
I get bounced off
or I hurt my back do you see that okay
so we can work with this one you're
doing Tessa right come around good okay
and so when I go down I don't want to go
into
this okay boom I have to go into
this I'm not
50/50 but I'm not off of that rear angle
okay all right let's have you guys
turny good come on let's go let's go
let's go let's
go
good okay and we'll switch rolls
[Music]
okay okay so there's one adjustment that
you made Taylor that that you did not
make you have The Stance but you did not
did not make it and so I'm going to ask
you some questions to get in there okay
you did not have to take aami Taylor and
you had to take ukmi Sean now why did
you not have to take ukemi the
penetration wasn't there was no
penetration there so you had the last
stance but it's not close enough do you
see that the range the range capacity of
the incorrect stance and the correct
stance are not the same the correct
stance does not have the same amount of
range penetration do you get it it has
better range Integrity better I'm sorry
penetration Integrity but does not have
the same range capacity
okay your change that you made was I
didn't go as far out on my angle of
deflection angle deviation I adopted the
my for the
edmi you kept the same old angle
deflection angle deviation range my for
the old range
penetration capacity do do you get that
okay now
though let's go back and and realize
there's a reason for
that let's look at the technique okay go
slow and uh here we go what's that what
did you just
do what did you just
do um what's that called A Clash that's
a block and there's no blocks in there's
no block in iido okay now if he F if he
full on through that
strike that little block isn't going to
stop that weapon do do you get it so I
don't want you to to kill him but kind
of give it some some energy do you see
okay what are you supposed to do so so
what kind of training are we doing
there um we're just working to be strong
strong no
that's we do do that training and it's
in you that's why you did it but the
understanding is not
accurate so in other words I do hold my
Joe up and he does touch
it but I'm not blocking it I'm not
trying to be strong you that's what
that's you understood that okay what are
we doing
instead we what's that training called
the other one is called called
application this one's called what
starts with a
e EMB embryonic okay so what I'm doing
in embryonic training is his weapon
stops being a Joe and it is now an angle
that I can use to draw what Parker calls
complimentary
angles that will make up my combined
line of attack line of defense meaning
my defense the shielding of my body is
in my attacking of his body okay and
this line is giving me a visual tactile
cue that I learn okay so the angle that
your Joe takes how it got
there yes that's the same and the angle
that it comes into for the attack
straight down his weapon now go ahead to
the hands don't move your feet cuz
that's
incorrect okay is my line of attack but
I'm not blocking it do you get it okay
so let's go back and now that we're on
the same page go back please and let's
get the right M go here we go go go do
it again embryonic do embryonic Sean you
try it again
Sean go okay
state state
and I'll trade out with you okay all
right we know for you to get power the
right hand has to go underneath and you
have to
mimic basically
makos got it and then it comes
up and now you do that stance okay got
it okay so let's rewind the
film and we'll trade out cuz we only
have three people here you're going to
use yours and you're going to go back
onto his head
okay all right Sean you're going to do
that same thing you're going to put that
right hand underneath you cool stop go
back a little go back a little go back a
little and you need to hit his
hands there you go stop
okay this is this
correct no it's too narrow you need to
give yourself that extra inch do you see
and now you want to move your body don't
leave your right hand where it is cuz
that we know know that this my is
correct now we know my right hand is
supposed to be under my body okay so
it's not right now it's forward so we're
going to move my body forward move that
whole stance move your foot too no no no
you're confused you stepped in the wrong
place go back where you were stay there
stay there
please you're going to leave the right
hand
here in space and you're going to move
your Han me your whole Han me forward
move your whole Han me move the whole
Han me that's too
much here get your foot back get your
right foot back do you get it do you
understand now stay there now you are in
the right place for power on the right
hand weight over the Joe and the right
amount of margin for error on the attack
that you're trying to do got it okay
let's rewind the
film and look at where you are to his
body now it is much closer do you see
that before you were probably another 8
in
away from him the chest to chest
distance do you see okay so let's go
ahead go back 8
in cool come
down and let's do our correct
EDI and you'll see that you'll under
penetrate do you see okay now let's go
back let's get ourselves where we need
to be you could T you could find it the
way I told you to find it so go ahead
and strike the hands so that you have
that extra inch on the other side of the
target do you understand see that that's
what you want see there that's a basic
of stick fighting
okay now let's move my
body there you go all right and now
let's
do the correct edme and you'll see
plenty of plenty of penetration do you
see that okay so if we go
um
please if we're going here and I'm like
out here then I would tell you that you
missed you missed and this doesn't have
the right penetration either okay but
also very common let we go again right
I'm over here and then oh I barely got
it you see I barely got it you look at
that barely got it and then I don't
really have it either okay but if you
start going start at the top and I'm
here like and I'm hitting those hands
and you can see how close my range my
chest to chest range is on him to do
boom and then you have plenty of
penetration okay do you guys see that
yes okay so the other one makes
everything else wrong makes it all not
work can you see it's not Marshall
because I don't even have the range of
penetration because in order for it to
even get close to working I got to block
and miss your hands and not penetrate
down to your Center which is the
definition of a Toshi right boom I got
to drop your Center not just hit your
hands all right I got to cut an angle
that's going through your Center and
that's going to require that extra inch
over the handam strike which again is
consistent with levers when you're using
levers six batons you got to give that
margin for error you can't just aim on
the tip okay um but it gets all wrong
it's not biomechanically sound and it is
not martially sound it all just goes to
but everyone does it because
it looks like
iido it is to me looks stupid it looks
stupid as all hell is what it looks like
okay because I don't fall for the style
anymore I I see it I go now it would
never work I see the back you see h